bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans sa vous regarde ce
soir myth et réalité sur l'aide médicale
d'État bonsoir Patrick stéphanini
bonsoir et merci beaucoup d'être notre
grand témoin ce soir vous êtes un grand
spécialiste des questions migratoires un
homme de droite aussi mais vous avez
remis avec l'ancien ministre de la Santé
socialiste claudévin un rapport très
attendu sur l'ame l'aide mé d'tat
rapport remig guerre à elliizabeth borne
qui B embrèche certaines idées de votre
famille politique qui lève de nombreux
lièvres aussi des dysfonctionnements
dont on va parler dans le détail dans la
deuxème partie tout à l'heure notre
grand débat ce soir Airbnb faut-il
encore serré la vis partout dans les
grandes villes la prolifération des
meublés touristiques est devenu un
problème en pleine crise du logement les
plateforme de location de courte durée
continue à bloquer le marché alors
fautil Durc encore les règles une
proposition de loi est débattue en ce
moment même dans l'hémicycle et nous en
parlons avec mes invités dans un instant
sur ce plateau enfin nos affranchis ce
soir l'économie Fanny guinochet le
regard du professeur Yanis roder sur le
choc des savoirs de Gabriel hatal et
puis Bourbon Express Elsa monondinava
voilà pour le menu on y va Patrick
stéphanini ça vous regarde ça commence
tout de
suite
[Musique]
c'est devenu le cauchemar des maires des
villes touristiques en France qui
n'arrivent plus à loger leurs propres
habitants Airbnb la plateforme
américaine de location meublé de courte
durée et dans le collumateur depuis des
années d'ailleurs un peu partout dans
dans le monde New York Amsterdam ont
même drastiquement régulé le marché mais
faut-il en France aller jusque là
bonsoir Olga givernet bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
renaissance de lin porte-parole du
groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée vous
défendez donc cette proposition de loi
transpartisane avec le Parti socialiste
et Renaissance défendu d'ailleurs en ce
moment même dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée bonsoir maître Xavier de
mezois bonsoir merci d'être là avocat
spécialiste de la question Airbnb vous
défendez les propriétaires qui recourent
à ces plateformes de de location c'est
une activité que vous pratiqué depuis
des années je précise que on a
évidemment invité rbnb he qui qui n'a
pas souhaité participer à ce débat
bonsoir Franck Rolland bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes le porte-parole du
collectif national des habitants
permanents qui bataille contre Airbnb et
toutes les plateformes du même type
enfin bonsoir jean-virgil Crance ravi de
vous accueillir vous présidez la
Confédération des acteur du tourisme
donc vous défendez le tourisme mais en
même temps vous êtes l'adjoint au maire
de saint-malot ville sil en est envahi
par les locations Airbnb on va entrer
dans le détail tout à l'heure Patrick
stéphanini n'hésitez pas à intervenir he
quand vous le souhaitez ou même à
interroger nos invités on plante le
décor je vais le faire mais je j'indique
tout de suite que je ne suis pas
totalement objectif car vous m'avez
invité ce soir au titre de l'aide
médicale d'État et nous en parlerons
dans la seconde partie de l'émission
absolument mais il se trouve qu'à titre
professionnel je travaille pour une
association d'hôteliers qui s'appelle la
top donc je connais assez bien sujet que
vous allez aborder dans la la première
partie mais je je veux que les choses
soient clairesette transpar pas
totalement objectif et ben voilà donc
vous défendez les hôteliers et si on
peut dire première partie concerné par
par ce ce dossier donc n'hésitez pas on
plante le décor d'abord qu'est-ce que
propose cette cette loi et et le cadre
juridique aujourd'hui qu'est-il et bien
on voit cela avec Stéphane Blakowski
dans son chrono tout de
suite allez je me retourne pour vous
vous accueillir je vous invite à faire
la même chose pour écouter Stéphane
dakovski bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Mariam
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors alors où
je vous parle tout le monde est au
courant la France traverse une crise du
logement mais le problème c'est que tout
le monde a beau être au courant bah la
crise continue de s'amplifier si bien
que bah certains responsables politiques
finissent par employer des formules choc
regardez en octobre Édouard Philippe
disait attention pénurie de logement
égale risque de bombe sociale enfin cela
dit il n'avait rien avant puisque un an
auparavant Olivier clin qui était
ministre du Logement disait exactement
la même chose attention risque de bombe
sociale d'ailleurs le terme bombe
sociale c'est répandu dans la presse et
ça on parle du nouvelle HSE voyez Hop
qui est à gauche et qui parle lui aussi
de risque de bombe sociale par rapport à
cette crise le Figaro dit exactement la
même chose attention risque de bombe
sociale alors cette crise du logement
elle est certes lié à des facteurs qui
nous échappent comme par exemple la
hausse des taux d'intérêt mais elle est
aussi liée à des domaines où on peut
intervenir par exemple il y a environ 1
million de logements en France qui sont
mis en location sur les sites genre rbnb
booking Abritel il faut citer trois
marques he pour éviter les remarques de
publicité illicite donc tous ces
logements dont je vous parle sont
consacrés au logement enfin touristique
et du coup il deviennent indisponibl
pour ceux qui habitent qui vivent qui
travaillent sur place donc voyez un peu
la carte voilà ce sont les zones les
plus concernées en rouge ce sont les
métropoles Paris Bordeaux Toulouse vous
les reconnaîtrez où depuis de nombreuses
années 7 8 ans déjà on lutte contre
l'implantation de Airbnb puis en orange
ce sont les zones plus touristiques qui
à leur tour sont obligé de d'être
confrontés à ce phénomène donc on voit
que tout le littoral évidemment est
concerné puisque c'est là que les gens
veent venir évidemment plus c'est beau
plus on y va donc le sud-est et alors la
Corse les pauvres comme c'est l'île de
beauté ils sont les premierers concernés
sur ce sujet mais si on veut changer les
lois en France si on veut vraiment
changer les choses qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire il faut changer les lois et c'est
à l'assemblée que ça se passe et là je
le dis mais vraiment j'ai pas peur de le
dire même si je le CP bravo les députés
bravo les députés parce qu'ils ont fait
au point une loi transpartisane qui
devraisêtre voté aujourd'hui qui est en
trois articles pour calmer les appétits
de harbnb donc trois articles 3 2 1 je
vous fais le compte à rebour donc
l'article 3 ce sont des propriétaires
qui louent aujourd'hui sur rbnb qui
bénéficient d' abattement pardon de 71 %
et bien la loi va modifier ce point-là
le taux va passer à 50 % ce qui revient
pour le même tô que pour les meublés
classiques article 2 donc ça c'est un un
point un peu plus confus parce que en
fait on va offourir une boîte à outil au
merire pour leur permettre d'intervenir
localement prendre des décisions pour
autoriser interdire réglementer
l'implantation de ces meublés de
tourisme vous allez pouvoir y revenir et
puis voilà article 1 le le le dernier de
mon compte àbour c'est que aujourd'hui
quand vous devez mettre un logement en
location vous êtes obligatoirement
soumis à le DPE vous savez ce que c'est
que c'est le diagnostique pardonn
dites-moi diagnostic de performance
énergétique voilà en tout cas tout le
monde sait que ce sont ces lettres qui
indiquent si votre logement retient la
chaleur donc c diagnostique est
obligatoire pour toutes les locations
sauf pour rbnb qui en sont dispensés si
vous louz sur de cette manière là et
bien est-ce que vous trouvez ça juste
non non évidemment rassurez-vous ça va
changer c'est annaïlemmer qui est donc
la rapport de projet de loi don parle
aujourd'hui qui l'exlique avait une
stratégie d'évitement c'estàd que les
gens pour ne pas faire la rénovation de
leur bâtiment de leur habitat et m
mettit en fait sur des plateformes de
courte durée leur logement c'était en
fait une stratégie d'évidement et du
coup on s'est retrouvé en perte de
logement en fait de longue durée
c'est-à-dire que nos salariés nos nos
étudiants nos saisonniers n'avaient plus
de logement à l'année donc on se dit ben
s'il y a cette contrainte qui a amené en
fait un évitement mais il faut appliquer
la contrainte partout bon voilà j'ai
essayé de placer un peu les grandes
lignes ligne du débat je serais bien
rester débattre avec vous j'ai bossé
toute la journée sur le dossier mais il
y a pas de place autour de la table donc
je vous fais confiance hein allez on va
essayer d'être à la hauteur merci
beaucoup Stéphane blakovski je vais
commencer avec vous jeanv Gill Crance
parce que vous vous êtes la Jo auire
d'une ville touristique s'il en est
saint-malot décrivez-nous exactement
l'état du marché locatif aujourd'hui
dans cette ville en combien de temps
Airbnb et ses concurrents on ont
transformer la ville on explosé sur le
marché du locatif en meublé alors
peut-être si vous permettez un un un mot
introductif peut-être sur le la
l'expression
Airbnb utilisée je pense qu'en fait le
le sujet il est lié à une crise du
logement il est lié à une régulation en
fait de l'urbanisme et donc c'est pas
tant Airbnb qui est en fait une
plateforme de distribution qui peut
l'être comme d'autres plateformes comme
ça a été mentionné et donc en effet on
travaille sur une politique globale du
logement et de l'urbanisme sur la la
taille d'une d'uneû ville mais
saint-malot franchement concrètement
quand on arrive sur les remparts c'est
impressionnant le changement quand même
on entend les les Valis à roulette des
touristes qui cherchent leur emplacement
non je me trompe l'idée en fait c'est en
effet de de réguler d'encadrer un marché
qui ne l'a pas été au départ il s'est
développé de façon très rapide il faut
reconnaître que si aujourd'hui il s'est
développé c'est qu'il répond à une
attente de clientèle mais pour autant il
doit être encadré et régulé nous n
sommes partis du principe puisque vous
m'interrogez sur saint-malot même si je
suis venu là pour plutôt représenter
l'économie touristique dans son
c'est très cl donc là on est vraiment
sur la déf dit pour exemple de de
saint-malot il est dans le cadre de la
ville fortifiée si il y avait eu aucune
disposition de prise on peut imaginer
que au bout de quelques années on se
serait retrouvé sans quasiment aucun
habitant et là c'est tout l'écosystème
en fin de compte qui est mis à mal franc
Roland je crois que vous connaissez bien
cette ville parce que ça permet par un
exemp ex de se figurer les choses même
si on verra un reportage après tout à
fait enfin en tout cas pour sint Malo ça
a été effectivement révélateur que les
le trop plein de de LCD finalement a
fait accélérer révéler et la question du
du logement et c'est vrai que il a fallu
agir très vite et c'est pour ça que
notamment il y a eu le le collectif
samalog VGS qui s'est créé notamment si
je suis un salarié que je veux trouver
un meublé en un an pour un an ou ou un
étudiant saint-malot je peux encore le
trouver ou c'est extrêmement tendu c'est
extrêmement tendu il y a de phénomène
qui sont la pénurie de logement et le
prix de l'immobilier c'est deux les deux
choses qui sont qui sont effectivement
qui empêchent en tout cas des gens qui
travaillent un couple qui qui
travaillent de pouvoir trouver donc ça
amène effectivement une difficulté à à
rester sur Saint-Malo et donc à devoir
peut-être partir parce qu'effectivement
avant on partait de Bretagne pour parce
qu'il y avait pas de travail maintenant
on part parce qu'on peut pas se loger le
maire on a bien entendu Stéphane
blackakovski Olga givernet va avoir un
peu plus de pouvoir ses outils de
régulation à Paris ça c'est l'exemple
typique très clairement maintenant il y
a des quotas c'est simple à nidalgo vous
êtes obligé d'obtenir une autorisation
pour faire du Airbnb et autres si le
quota est déjà atteint c'est non vous ne
pouvez pas le faire et il y a eu
beaucoup de contentieux on va y venir
mais aujourd'hui la règle elle est
appliqué elle est très claire qu'est-ce
que cette loi va changer pour les maires
ils pourront faire la même chose qu'à
Paris alors ils vont pouvoir justement
décider en fait s'ils donneent cette
autorisation moi je le sais bien je suis
dans l'un pays dejx dans les montagnes
ces communes sont touristiques et on
sait que la pénurie a fait que il y a eu
une fuite des usages des logements vers
ces meublés touristiques donc c'est la
possibilité de remettre les maires en en
en décision sur cela et de pouvoir
attribuer la possibilité ou non de ces
logements à être touristique c'est très
important parce que dans partir de
combien quoi c'est quoi toutes les
villes de plus de 50000 toutes les
villes alors là l'objectif notamment sur
le fait que il y a eu aussi la surtaxe
sur les résidences secondaires c'est ESS
de remettre ces communes je crois pas
que ce soit plutôt une taille mais mais
vraiment une attribution de ces villes
balnéaires qui se transformment
complètement en fait avec du tourisme et
que finalement leurs habitants sont
obligés de d'aller beaucoup plus loin
surtout des personnes qui travaillent
dans dans la commune donc c'est de
pouvoir remettre entre les mains des des
maires la capacité de choisir et de et
de dire en fait que leur ville ne doit
pas être une ville simplement
touristique donc c'est le maire qui aura
le dernier mot ça va tout changer pour
vous ça maître de aujourd'hui c'est très
compliqué il y a 49 villes au total qui
ont mis en place des autorisations
préalables des maires Paris évidemment
biaris Strasbourg euh c'est c'est les
communes les grandes communes hein c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites par que
pas plus tard qu'hier je plaidis le
premier dossier de la ville de Lille qui
poursuivait un propriétaire j'ai défendu
250 personnes à la ville de Paris j'ai
battu la ville de Lyon sur ce
contentieux pourquoi je vous dis ça
c'est que seuls les grandes villes à mon
sens ont la capacité financière
juridique et politique de mener euh la
boîte à outil qui va être offert
peut-être par la députée ce soir de
pouvoir contraindre de donner ou pas des
autorisations de sanctiontionner et
cetera je donne souvent cet exemple qui
est parlant à quoi bon d'installer des
radars sur les routes si les communes
n'ont ni les moyens ni le fonctionnement
pour acheter ses radars et derrière
mettre des amendes et j'ai un petit peu
peur et je crains que derrière cette
bonne volonté de donner des pouvoirs aux
élus locaux je m'imagine mal comment les
petites communes françaises vont pouvoir
mettre en en pratique le parce que c'est
bien beau de mettre des lois mais il
faut pouvoir les appliquer et les
sanctionner aujourd'hui je crains je
crains vraiment que ces communes
n'auront pas la capacité de le faire
Fran Rolland oui je je je voulais juste
pour faire du tac au tac par rapport à
votre remarque indiquer que dans nos
propositions du Collectif national pour
des habitants permanents on a la demande
qu'effectivement il y ait un
accompagnement de l'État par rapport aux
villes qui ont des difficultés à mettre
ça en place puisque effectivement Airbnb
ne cesse d'attaquer les villes pour
retarder la mise en place de
réglementation et je tiens à préciser
quand même que dans la boîte à outils
c'est pour ça qu'on a notamment monté ce
collectif national il est nécessaire
impérativement de déclarer en zone
tendue pour pouvoir mettre en place une
réglementation et une régulation or sur
36000 communes en France il n'y a que
3600 actuellement communes qui ont cette
possibilité là ce qui est un peu
étonnant quand on sait qu'une zone
tendue détermine effectivement défin un
territoire qui a un problème de logement
donc c'est un peu étonnant qu'il n'y ait
que 3600 communes et on peut s'étonner
qu'il y en ait pas plus c'est notre
souit voà il sont en train de débattre
je suis sûr que vous vous avez réussi à
leur faire passer vos arguments aux
députés qui qui qui débattent il y il y
a déjà eu une augmentation du nombre de
ces communes hein il y a eu un certain
nombre de communes au-dessus de 100000
habitants qui ont été qui ont été mais
mais pour bien comprendre c'est c'est
c'est particulier hein toutes ces tous
ces contentieux il est énorme le
contentieux à la fois la plateforme
attaque les propriétaires attaquent
également alors c'est surtout les les
grandes villes comme Paris et Paris
illustre bien le contentieux puisqu'ils
ont poursuivi quand même 700 personnes
c'est colossal en 3 ans et ils ont perdu
d'ailleurs un très grand nombre de
dossiers sur une faille juridique qui va
peut-être d'ailleurs être corrigée ce
soir mais effectivement aujourd'hui la
la ville symbole c'est Paris hein c'est
Paris et alors c'est intéressant de
parler de Paris parce que on a les Jeux
Olympiques dans 6 mois on n'est pas
certain d'avoir des métros pour
transporter les touristes parce
qu'àidalgo nous dit que les métros ne
vont peut-être pas tous fonctionner par
contre je peux juste vous garantir une
chose c'est qu'on aura pas de problème
pour loger les touristes grâce à Airbnb
et ça personne ne va en parler autour la
ce soir bah les hôtels peuvent engranger
300000 personnes on a 14 millions de
touristes qui viennent qui va pouvoir
faire la différence aujourd'huib et là
on entend personne pour venir dire qu'on
va réussir nos jeux olympiques grâce à
cette plateforme forc de constater que
c'est une réalité jeanvgil CR il y a la
question du tourisme c'est vrai que ceux
qui bénéficient d'Airbnb ceux qui lou ce
sont plutôt les classes moyennes en
vacances ou des classes moyennes qui
arrondissent le leur fin de mois avec
avec une résidence principale loué l'été
vous vous dites franchement si on régule
on risque de perdre les touristes et
donc l'attractivité économique non il
alors il y a un point qui est très clair
c'est que il faut partir d'un principe
que une destination touristique
l'attractivité d'une destination
touristique elle est faite avant tout de
son offre son offre sur trois critères
qui sont à la fois la quantité la
qualité et la diversité vous avez
compris que sur ce troisième critère
bien entendu on peut retrouver de la
location de de meublé donc ce que nous
disons au niveau des acteurs du tourisme
et beaucoup d'élus locaux sont aussi
dans cette démarche c'est de pas
supprimer un pan d'activité il faut le
réguler il faut probablement aussi
l'encadrer il faut probablement lui
apporter aussi des règles qui soient
proches des autres types d'hébergement
hein on peut penser à la sécurité à
l'accessibilité à d'autres éléments mais
ça à la limite c'est un c'est une autre
partie du du sujet mais il y a besoin en
effet de de réguler alors la demande en
effet des des acteurs de l'économie
touristique était en effet d'avoir cette
boîte à outil et dans le cadre
d'ailleurs de nos discussions au sein de
la confédération des acteurs du tourisme
nous avons donc multiples fédérations et
on a bien vu euh si vous voulez la
nécessité de pouvoir traiter au plus
près du territoire le sujet
Z mêème pas les M la régulation par la
boesure pour les ma on continue de
débattre je voudrais qu'on se figure un
peu mieux les choses en image on va
prendre la direction de Bayon dans le
Pays-Bas Stéphanie Despierre a suivi
justement l'auteur de cette proposition
de loi avec Madame lur an l pour
Renaissance il s'appelleaki et regardez
reportage
à Bayonne le phénomène rbnb a changé la
physionomie du quartier historique là
entre 2015 et 2020 il y a plusieurs
dizaines de logements rien que dans
cette rue qui sont devenus des rbnb donc
permanent et cheveri militant pour le
droit au logement guide le député
socialiste inyaki et chaniz avec
l'arrivée des plateformes de location en
ligne il y a de moins en moins
d'appartements disponibles pour les
locaux ce trè étage là là il y avait un
couple de jeunes travailleurs qui payit
un loyer de 500 € comme ça la
propriétaire les a fait dégager et a
transformé ça en
Airbnb qui se louait du coup à autour de
100 € la nuit les habitants ont de plus
en plus de mal à se loger et
l'exaspération monte ça c'est le drapeau
que met de plus en plus d'habitant pour
demander le droit à vivre et se loger au
pays aujourd'hui dans l'agglomération de
B 21 % des logements sont des résidences
secondaires bien conscient du problème
le député Inaki et chaniz veut changer
la loi on en est à cette situation là
parce qu'on a jamais rien réglementé sur
la question effectivement il y a New
York qui a pris des mesures c'est le cas
en Allemagne c'est le cas en Italie et
la France on est un petit peu bon
dernier dans la réglementation de rirbnb
on voit même aujourd'hui des territoires
qui l'interdisent et on je pense on est
plusieurs à le penser que avant
d'interdire rbnb il y a des mesures de
réglementation à apporter pour endiguer
la crise du logement sur la côte basque
les communes ont choisi la manière forte
désormais chaque propriétaire qui met en
location un appartement de vacances doit
obligatoirement en mettre un deuxième en
location à l'année un système très
contraignant qui provoque la colère des
propriétaires comme Carla qui souhaite
rester anonyme franchement on ne pensait
à aucun moment qu'on allait nous
interdire de faire ce que l'on veut de
notre résidence secondaire Carla vit
dans l'intérieur du Pays-Basque en 2015
elle a acheté de pièces près de l'océan
elle le loue 5 mois par an via les
plateformes en ligne on voudrait pas
devenir les les bouqu émissaires du
manque de logement on comprend pas
pourquoi les communes n'ont pas fait le
nécessaire depuis 20 ans à faire de la
construction avec les nouvelles règles
carla ne pourra plus louer son
appartement au touristes alors qui veut
répondre à cette propriétaire olgaernet
puis Monsieur Roland St après
effectivement on peut dire pourquoi on
peut pas construire on peut pas
construire plus il faut savoir queon a
quand même aussi une volonté de zéro
artificialisation nette de
rationalisation du du du logement moi je
travaille sur la sobriété la sobriété
notamment dans le logement c'est de
prendre en compte que le nombre de
mètres carrés habitaable par habitant
augmente elle vous dit j'ai une
résidence secondaire peuxallouer alors
que de toute façon elle serait vide
alors que les logements sont de enfin
sont son ne sont sont de plus en plus
petits il y a beaucoup de raisons à cela
mais en l'occurrence c'est vrai que les
logements vacants et les logements qui
sont résidenceces secondairirees sont
particulièrement ciblé parce que on veut
donner une priorité euh aux personnes
qui vont résider de manière permanente
ils vont habiter là ils vont faire
marcher les commerces ils vont aussi
travailler donc c'est important que ces
personnes-là soient pris en compte on ne
cible pas ces propriétaires qui avait
peut-être vu l'intérêt économique sur la
question de la fiscalité qui était
avantageuse il y a aussi un autre
intérêt notamment sur le DPE dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure et et et et et pour
nous ça crée une un appel d'air une
fuite pour pour éviter cette fiscalité
ou ces obligations environnementales
Fran Rolland pour bien comprendre parce
que c'est pas c'est un peu technique
mais sur les résidences excusez-moi
juste un élément important c'est que
c'est aussi un combat de dans nos
collectifs il y a aussi des
propriétaires donc comme vous avez
présenté l'avocat comme étant
effectivement le défenseur des
propriétaires il faut savoir que dans
nos collectifs il a des propriétaires
bien sûr qui sont des LO occasionnel et
non pas des professionnels de la
location parce qu'on parle bien de deux
choses différentes des compléments de
professionnel de la location personne
qui a un studio qui s sa petite
résidence secondaire ouou principale qui
s'en va et cetera donc on est sur une
petite location entre guillemets de
complément revu et on a des des loueurs
professionnels qui sont qui deviennent
une activité économique hors de
réglementation hors de régulation et on
parle bien de ça et c'est important le
le préciser pour bien comprendre parce
que faut se figurer des choses vous avez
des gens qui parce que ils ont un
appartement c'est pas leur résidence
secondaire au lieu de le louer en meublé
un an ou même en vide ils vont le louer
une semaine 3 jours pendant 360 ch ça
existe ça ça peut exister mais on parle
plutôt de multipropriétaires qui ont une
activité qui on 3 qu 5 appartements et
qui font une activité professionnelle
c'est de cela dont on parle et pour
effectivement et c'est important de
réguler cette activité ce troplin de de
location de courte durée et à terme
peut-être des risons secondaires tout
simplement parce que on sait que c'est
dans le parc immobilier existant qu'il
faut faire revenir du logement à l'année
et c'est vrai qu'on nous propose de
construire à toutoua alors que quelque
part c'est dans le logement
effectivement existant qu'il faut faire
avenir et donc ça sera une erreur en
tout
cas
notamment dans une période nécessaire de
sobriété de terrain Patrick stéphanini
oui moi je voudrais dire deux choses
d'abord les les hôteliers ne sont pas
hostiles aux location de longue durée de
courte durée par principe il s'agit d'un
phénomène économique nouveau c'est une
sacrée concurrence quand même bien sûr
que c'est une sacrée concurrence mais le
combat des hôteliers c'est un combat
pour la juste
concurrence que la location de courte
durée soit un nouveau mode d'hébergement
touristique choisi par des millions de
Français et qui correspond aux
aspirations de ces Français ça n'est pas
contestable en revanche ce qui est
contestable dans la situation actuelle
et je crois que la proposition de loi a
pour objet de d' remédier ce qui est
contestable c'est c'est l'inégalité de
concurrence et les deux caractéristiques
qui ont été citées dans l'émission
c'est-à-dire l'avantage fiscal de 711 %
c'est un avantage fiscal qui dans le
droit fiscal français est exorbitant du
droit commun si vous prenez les les il
se justifie comment d'ailleurs si vous
prenez les autres régimes fiscaux vous
trouverez pas d'abattement sur le revenu
à un taux de 71 % pourquoi on l'
deuxèment et deuxièmement ça a été dit
le le fait que les locations de courte
durée échappe au au DPE alors que le DPE
va commencer à s'appliquer de enfin a
commencé à s'appliquer de manière
contraignante pour tous les
propriétaires qui qui louent à à l'année
bah ça crée une inégalité de concurrence
donc nous avons besoin besoin d'un
instrument de régulation et par rapport
à un phénomène économique nouveau et
j'ajouterai juste un mot ou si nous ne
légiférons pas en France l'Europe le
fera pour nous puisqu'il y a un projet
de règlement européen qui s'appelle STR
qui est en cours d'adoption et on
s'approche de son adoption qui comporte
des dispositions très intéressantes et
et dont le législateur français pourrait
utilement s'inspir alors personne
s'intéresse personne s'intéresse au
propriétaires moi moi j'en reçois des
des centaines hein donc c'est des gens
qui qui ont des des studios et C ils ont
tous la même histoire personne ne les
écoute personne n'a pensé à les écouter
en rédigeant cette loi la plupart du
temps ils ont un studio en résidence
secondaire ce sont des déçus de la
longue durée c'est-à-dire que c'est des
gens qui avaient un studio qui avec avec
un impayé un un locataire qui payait pas
ils ont mis des années à l'expulser
parce que le droit n'est pas de leur
côté aujourd'hui ils ont un appartement
qui était en désordre et ils se sont dit
un jour mais ça suffit Airbnb arrive en
France en 2016 et leur dit écoutez nous
avec nous ça va être simple vous n'aurez
plus ces problèmes là vous serez payés
et en plus vous pourrez récupérer votre
appartement une se semaine par an si
vous voulez voir vos enfants à Paris et
ceter on peut comprendre le point de vue
du propriétaire mais en pleine crise du
logement vous pouvez pas vous louz dans
vot a de Ch y a deux éléments aussi qui
ont pas été dit c'est que 92 % des
locations de courte durée c'est moins de
120 jours par an ça veut dire qu'en fait
ce sont des gens c'est leur résidence
principale donc ça sur qu étude on en a
discuté un financement pr expqu ce que
je veux expliquer c'est qu'une majorité
de logement en France sont loués en
résidence principale ça ve dire c'est
des logements que de toute façon ne
pourrait pas louer à des saisonniers
puisque par définition ce sont les gens
ou l'endroit où ils habitent ce sont
pendant les vacances Noël et cetera où
la famille part et quitte le logement
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça au fond
c'est vrai vous vous auriez pu mettre un
plafond de nuité plus bas que que celui
qui existe notamment à Paris c'est 4
mois 120 jour 120 jours ça va être
réduit ça pass 90 c'est s attendez le le
débat n'est pas fini donc c'est
difficile de se de se positionner
j'aimerais revenir sur l'histor du fait
d'avoir ce plafond fiscal qui était
aussi intéressant c'était parce qu'à
l'époque il manquait de de logement
touristique pour la l'afflux de
touristes que nous avions en France
aujourd'hui ça s'est rééquilibré grâce à
Airbnb et cette plateforme c'est très
bien puisqu'elle a mis en relation les
propriétaires avec des personnes qui
avaient des besoins de logement à courte
à courte durée P que ce sera dissuasif
maintenant
il on parlait de on parlait de de
concurrence effectivement il peut y
avoir une certaine concurrence déloyale
alors que les personnes se soit projeté
sur euh un logement comme cela qui va
permettre de de d'avoir un peu de
financement c'est très bien et que les
nouveaux qui feront ce choix-là
lorsqu'il y aura la nouvelle loi ils
prendront en compte les contraintes
qu'il y a aujourd'hui c'est c'est le
transfert qui qui pose problème le DP
simplement je voudrais juste finir le le
le DPE qui n'était pas obligatoire
aujourd'hui ça veut dire que c'est des
logements qui sortent complètement et
qui ne pourront pas revenir sur le
résidentiel donc il y aura des travaux
des propriétaires pour les mettre aux
normes éviter les les passoirs
thermiques fr Rolland je pense qu'il
faut qu'on parle aussi des
copropriétaires parce que c'est très
compliqué dans les villes où il y a
beaucoup d'Airbnb pour les voisins qui
voient défiler énormément de lo tour
lorsquon parleit des désagréments voir
des nuisances voir des violences quelque
part puisque vous imaginez de subir tous
les tris jours un déménagement hein vous
n'avez plus de voisin à l'année donc
plus de relations amicales et vous
subissez ces ces éléments là et puis il
arrive quand même on en entend parler
souvent quand même quelques désagrément
des gens qui font la fête et cetera et
cetera donc je pense que si on équilibre
les choses les nuisances sont identiques
par contre je voulais préciser sur
l'abattement c'est un élément important
on focalise sur le régime forfaitaire
alors qu'on sait parce que effectivement
on a les informations qu'on a transmis
d'ailleurs aux conseillers des
différents ministères que la plupart des
multipropriétaires donc les loueurs
professionnels qui sont sur une activité
économique déloyale par rapport
derilleurs aux hôteliers sont désormais
passés au régime réel et donc tout le
monde le sait et on espère qu'en tout
cas la mission parlementaire Dean qui
débutera en janvier puisse effectivement
s'attaquer au vrai problème qui n'est
pas le régime forfaitaire puisqu'ils
sont tous désoris passés au régime réel
com comme chacun sait jeanvgel CR ouais
sur le juste sur la partie fiscale il
faut se rappeler aussi que je vous
citais l'exemple entre le littoral et le
montagnire il y a un vrai sujet sur la
politique des ce qu'on appelle les
litfroids et où il y a eu des
incitations aussi et aujourd'hui il y a
encore d'ailleurs une réflexion sur la
gestion de ce
parc que je veux juste quand même red
meublé c'est la même avantage fiscal ça
c'est justice non oui oui bien sûr bien
sûr mais l'historique sur les élément de
d'historique vous interveniez maître en
disant que en effet la majorité des
locations aujourd'hui étaient donc des
des locations à l'année bah écoutez
heureusement en tout cas que on a encore
un parc immobilier de location classique
et après la préoccupation par rapport
aux gens qui font cette location de
façon temporaire un je pense que notre
préoccupation en tout cas quand on parle
pour un élu local c'est avant tout les
habitants de son territoire et de
pouvoir garder les habitants de son
territoire ceux qui ils sont nés et ceux
qui travaillent et ceux qui vivent et et
bien entendu les générations qui suivent
et on voit des territoires sur lequel
vous avez déjà aujourd'hui des
difficultés avec l'emploi une situation
de l'emploi qui est tendue et en plus
vous avez des entreprises qui vous
disent ça fait 6 mois je cherche un
candidat je l'ai trouvé malheureusement
je vais pas pouvoir le garder parce
qu'il peut pas se loger donc vous avez
de façon sy encore une fois une question
d'équ des élément qui sont qui sont on
est pas aux règles drastiques de de New
York ou Amsterdam vous en convenez tous
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'hôtellerie
ou rien quasiment à New York avec des
prix faut quand même le reconnaître qui
ont qui ont énormément flambé le juste
équilibre pour vous c'est c'est quoi le
mot de la fin madame c'est déjà cette
loi et je crois qu'il y a une grande loi
qui va arriver ensuite donc il faudra
trouver l'équilibre et moi je voudrais
dire simplement aux propriétaires
qu'effectivement ils ont bénéficié
davantage pendant plusieurs années et
qu'aujourd'hui on revient sur un un
équilibre et il faut qu'une un partage
de tous bon on s'arrête là on verra
voilà comment les les députés s'enarent
de ce sujet s'il y a des amendements
pour aller encore plus loin que que le
texte initial en tous les cas merci
beaucoup d'être venu débattre sur ce
plateau vous restez avec moi Patrick
stéphanini dans une dizaine de minutes
les parties pris de nos affranchis ce
soir le regard du professeur Yanis roder
sur le choc des savoirs de Gabriel Atal
Fanny guinochet s'est aussi penché sur
la mauvaise note de la France dans le
classement PISA qui traduit aussi une
baisse de niveau de nos meilleurs
scientifiques les mathématicien en tête
et puis de quoi nous parlez-vous ce soir
elsamondin Gava dans Bourbon Express n
parle d'un texte déposé par la droite
qui donne du fil à retordre à la
majorité c'est sur l'accord
franco-algérien de 68 à tout à l'heure
les amis mais d'abord on se penche dans
le détail Patrick stéphanili dans sur
votre rapport rapport sur l'aide
médicale d'État qui était très attendu
vous avez même dû accélérer sa remise
elle arrive pileepoil à la veille du
débat parlementaire sur le projet de loi
immigration qui commence ce lundi on
regarde les principales mesures et on en
discute dans le détail juste après
l'invitation de Marco Pomier
[Musique]
si on vous invite Patrick stphanini
c'est parce que vous nous dites que
l'aide médical d'État l'ame est utile
mais qu'il faut l'adapter c'est la
conclusion de votre rapport très attendu
en plein examen du projet de loi
immigration dans le rapport nous
écrivons que laame n'est pas un facteur
d'attractivité en France moi je ne crois
pas qu'onigre en France pour bénéficier
de
la on vousrouveent dans coulisses des
campagnes homme de l'ombre de la droite
la légende raconte que vous êtes un
faiseur de roi Jacques Chirac à la
présidentielle de
1995 Valérie PCR pour la région
île-de-fance un coup de matre François
Fillon vainqueur de la primaire de 2016
ancien préfet ancien conseiller
ministériel à l'intérieur et au Conseil
d'État partisan d'une ligne ferme sur
l'immigration vous défendez pourtant
l'aide médicale d'État laisse pas sur le
bord du chemin sans soin un étranger
fut-il en situation irrégulière d'ors
qu'il est malade le coût de l'Ame vous
l'avez chiffré près d'un milliard
d'euros pour 400000 bénéficiaires en
2022 votre rapport rédigé avec claudvin
franchement plus à gauche que vous va à
l'encontre des affirmations du
rassemblement national et des
républicains votre famille politique
c'est un appel d'Er droite et extrême
droite réclame la suppression de l'Ame
pour la remplacer par une aide mic
d'urgence trop complexe rétorquez-vous
en pointant les risques de renoncement
aux soins avec des conséquences sur la
santé publique vous présenter aussi des
pistes d'évolution réduire la liste des
pathologies prises en charge par l'ame
resserrer certains critères
d'éligibilité bref quelques coups de
rabot objectif lutter contre les abus et
renforcer les contrôle alors ce soir on
a une question pour vous espérez-vous
que vos propositions intègrent le projet
de loi
immigration réponse alors on nous a
demandé qu'un jour après le début de la
mission on nous a demandé d'accélérer
nos travaux parce que le projet de loi
immigration arrivait à l'Assemblée
nationale plutôt que prévu et que sa
discussion allait commencer le 11
décembre du coup alors que initialement
on devait rendre notre rapport le 15
janvier nous l'avons rendu le weekend
dernier
euh vous avez l'impression d'être
instrumentalisé non je n'irai pas
jusqu'à là mais je je dirais simplement
que pour enterrer toute réforme de de la
non je crois pas mais je je dirais
simplement que nous avons mis sur la
table dans ce rapport une série de
propositions je crois qu'ell mérite
d'être discuté elles sont des de nature
législative selon vous donc au députés
de son AR si sou il y a beaucoup de
propositions qui sont de nature
législative donc au députés de s'en
emparer au gouvernement éventuellement
de de prendre l'initiative alors j'ai
cru comprendre que le gouvernement ne
souhaitait pas que la question de la me
soit traitée dans le cadre du projet de
loi actuel cavalier législatif répondons
aux arguments du du Sénat et aux
articles et on renvoie au au
réglementaire ou en tout cas après ce
texte ce qui est sans doute
juridiquement exact mais enfin c'est le
Conseil constitutionnel qui le dira en
dernier ressort en tout cas nos
propositions sont désormais sur la table
et et j'espère qu'elles
serviront à l'avenir je suis pas en
mesure de quantifier le calendrier
qu'elles serviront à l'avenir à réformer
laame car le le l'esprit de notre
rapport c'est de dire que laame est
utile mais que la me a besoin d'être
réformé alors justement on va on va
reprendre point par point déjà la
conclusion générale utile médicalement
utile socialement c'est globalement bien
géré l'aide médicale d'État en
France oui c'est c'est utile parce que
ça fournit une couverture santé aux
étrangers qui sont en situation irréguli
et que ça leur permet d'avoir cette
couverture en en consultant en ville
puisque dès lur qu'ils sont couverts par
laame ils peuvent se rendre en
consultation chez des médecins de ville
chez des praticiens libéraux et au fond
ça évite un afflux à l'hôpital que
l'hôpital serait dans l'incapacité de
supporter si on réduisait le panier de
soins de laame comme cela avait été
envisagé à un moment donné à ce qu'on
appelle les soins urgents h ça veut dire
que les services des urgences des
hôpitaux seraient absolument débordés
que probablement ça pourrait entraîner
une dégradation de la qualité des soins
dans les établissements hospitaliers et
qu'en tout cas ça entraînerait une
aggravation du déficitement en désaccord
avec la proposition de Bruno rotaillot
au Sénat on va sur le fond vous dites
très clairement que laame n'est pas un
facteur d'attractivité en France et
pourtant vous expliquez que si ça n'est
qu'un indicateur
de l'augmentation de l'immigration
irrégulière ça n'en est pas la cause
mais ça entretient les étrangers dans
une situation de clandestinité
expliquez-nous ça donc ce que nous
disons c'est que ça n'est pas un facteur
d'attractivité parce que les étrangers
qui viennent en France de manière
régulière ou de manière
irrégulière ils viennent pas à cause de
laame en général ils ignorent tout de
l'existence de la me ils viennent parce
que ils ont en France des membres de
leur famille qui en France une diaspora
importante correspondant à la
nationalité de leur pays d'origine ou
simplement parce que ils ont par exemple
envie de faire des études en France que
le système éducatif français de
meilleure qualité que le système
éducatif dans leur pays d'origine alors
en revanche que nous écrivons c'est que
clme est un facteur qui
facilite le maintien dans la
clandestinité et ça c'est un vrai sujet
pour notre pays puisque l'analyse du
profil des bénéficiaires de laame montre
qu' un un nombre important de
bénéficiaires de laame sont en France
depuis des années autrement dit c'est
pas une situation de clandestinité qui
dure 6 mois ou un an avant de trouver
avec des tentatives de régularisation de
leur séjour ou pas oui oui sans doute
entemêlé T qui pourrait leur ouvrir
aussi le droit à la Sécur sans doute ent
bien sûr sans doute entremêlé de
tentatives de régularisation mais enfin
le bilan il est là il y a grosso modo 18
% des bénéficiaire de laame qui en
bénéficie depuis plus de 5 ans euh et et
10 % qui en bénéficie et 5 % excusez-moi
qui en bénéficie depuis plus de 10 ans
donc on a une clandestinité de longue
durée et ça je pense que ça n'avait pas
été prévu par ceux qui ont inventé laame
du coup du coup du coup il y a les
arbitrages qui sont fait selon du coup
ça pose le problème des soins chroniques
parce que si vous restez longtemps dans
la clandestinité en France au bout d'un
moment vous pouvez avoir besoin de soins
de longue durée alors expliquez-nous ça
parce que c'est vrai que vous n'allez
pas vraiment sur le panier de soins en
détaillant maladie par maladie ou ou
soins par soin en revanche vous dites
qu'il existe des des étrangers en
situation irrégulière malades qui
arrivent déjà malad en France et qui
nécessite une prise en charge par
exemple de chimiothérapie de
radiothérapie de dialyse et donc avec
une prise en charge sur la longue durée
régulirem ça démarre par une prise en
charge au titre des soins urgents
prenons l'exemple d'un étranger qui ne
s'est pas fait dialyser depuis 2 ou 3
jours et qui arrive sur le territoire
avec un visa de tourisme et ben il a
besoin d'aller de toute urgence soit
dans une clinique soit dans un hôpital
pour se faire dialyser et au titre des
soins urgents il est accepté il est pris
en charge mais ensuite il va s'inscrire
dans un parcours de soins de de longue
durée ça on ne peut pas lui refuser non
on peut pas lui refuser mais on peut
quand même se poser la question de
savoir s'il n'aurait pas pu être soigné
dans son pays d'origine et il se trouve
que dans la législation française il y a
un titre de séjour le titre de séjour
pour soin le titre de séjour pour
étrangers malad c'est la la double
appellation de ce titre de séjour et
qu'une des conditions pour bénéficier de
ce titre de séjour c'est que
l'administration s'appuie sur l'avis
d'un collège de médecin qui vérifie s'il
intéressé peut ou non bénéficier des
soins pertinents dans son pays
d'origineès bien et ça ça n pas
aujourd'hu question là on ne se la pose
jamais au titre de laame c'est un
problème c'est et vous le pointez dans
ce rapport d'ailleurs vous parlez de
faille troublante notamment sur les
bénéficiaires aujourd'hui lorsqu'un
étranger fait l'objet d'une mesure
d'éloignement que ce soit administratif
au qtf ou expulsion pour menace à
l'ordre public il continue de pouvoir
bénéficier de cette fameuse e vous vous
voulez que ça change ça oui parce que
c'est quelque part c'est choquant le le
le comme son nom l'indique l'aide
médicale d'État c'est une aide d'État
qui est financé par l'ensemble des
contribuable français français ou
étranger d'ailleurs par l'ensemble des
contribuables résidents en France
et le fait qu'elle continue à bénéficier
à un étranger qui n'est plus seulement
un clandestin mais qui est quelqu'un
auquel le ministre de l'intérieur ou
l'autorité judiciaire ont ordonné de
quitter le territoire français ça pose
un problème de principe donc avec
claudvin nous proposons que tous les
étrangers qui font l'objet d'une mesure
d'éloignement fondée sur une menace à
l'ordre public les expulsions perdent le
droit à la M toujours sur les
bénéficiaires il y a évidemment
l'étranger lui-même qui peut en
bénéficier il y a ses enfants il y a son
conjoint et on découvre dans ce rapport
l'existence du cohabitant qui lui aussi
s'il est déclaré au moment de la demande
de de bénéficier de la me peut en
profiter qui sont les cohabitants B on
sait pas très bien et c'est totalement
dérogatoire au droit des des prestations
sociales en France donc là nous
proposons une mesure de clarification
nous proposons que seul soit considéré
comme ayant droit d'un bénéficiaire de
laame ces enfants mineurs et que pour le
reste tous les majeurs qu'il s'agisse de
son conjoint de son partenaire ou de son
concubin ou qu' il s'agisse de cette
catégorie originale du cohabitant et
bien doit voir leur situation examiner
au regard de l'Ame comme n'importe quel
autre impétrant qui demande le bénéfice
de laame et puis naturellement laame
c'est une aide qui est conditionnée à un
plafond de ressources si vous dépassez
un certain plafond de ressources qui est
de l'ordre de 800 € par mois vous n'avez
pas droit au bénéfice de laame et et
nous constatons avec claudvin que la
législation française ne Perm pas de
prendre en compte les ressources du
conjoint du concubin ou du partenaire ça
aussi ça nous paraîtêtre une anomalie
significative dans le fonctionnement de
laame et donc une des raisons pour
lesquelles il faut réformer laame laame
c'est important évidemment pour prévenir
les maladies graves qui d'ailleurs
pourrai coûter cher à l'assurance
maladie ou même qui pourrait être
transmise he au reste de de la
population il y a pas d'examen
systématique de santé quand on demande
la me j'ai j'ai découvert ça en les
rapport non il y en a pas lorsqu'un
étranger vient en France régulièrement
pour demander un titre de séjour après
avoir obtenu ce qu'on appelle un visa de
long séjour dans un consulat il fait
l'objet d'une visite médicale soit dans
son pays d'origine avant son départ vers
la France soit à son arrivée en France
en revanche pour les autres étrangers
qui s'agissent des demandeurs d'asile ou
qui s'agissent des
étrangers qui entrent en France
régulièrement ou irrégulièrement
euh et pour ceux qui sont entrés avec un
visa de cours séjour qui qui sont
clandestins au bout de quelques semaines
il y a pas du tout d'examen de santé là
là aussi ça permettrait de auss ça nous
interpelle il nous semble que ça
permettrait de repérer si l'étranger est
atteint d'une maladie infectieuseune
maladie contagieuse ça ça paraîttre la
moindre des choses ça permettrait
peut-être
de vérifier ce qu'on appelle le schéma
vaccinal c'est que l'intéressé a reçu
dans son pays d'origine ou pas les
vaccinations obligatoires et s'il les a
pas toutes reçu de les lui administré
toutes ces mesures ont un coût forcément
en moyen vous les avez chiffréoueses ces
mesures ont un coût nous n'avons pas
chiffré le le coût de ce bilan de santé
mais mais encore une fois dans un pays
comme les États-Unis il est absolument
hors de question d'entrer aux États-Unis
et d'
séjourner même irrégulièrement sans
qu'on se soit intéressé à votre état de
santé alors il y a beaucoup de choses en
fait hein finalement c'est c'est pas
quitus global à laame il y a beaucoup de
lièvre que vous soulevez et c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs là
informmatisation de la carte de
bénéficiaire parce que vous montrez
qu'il y a aussi des des fraudes je
renvoie à votre rapport qui est qui est
en ligne qui est publicque je voudrais
aussi vous interroger à titre plus
personnel parce que vous êtes aussi un
politique et là pas l'expert qui dépose
son rapport sur la version du du Sénat
on en a beaucoup parlé il y a une mesure
en particulier qui a suscité une levée
de bouclier le conditionnement des
allocation familiale à 5 ans de présence
sur le territoire contre 6 actuellement
5 an contre 6 est-ce que ça vous semble
mesuré proportionné
utile
alors autant l'ame n'est pas un facteur
d'attractivité en France autant la
possibilité de bénéficier en France de
prestations sociales non
contributiv sans qu'on prenne à aucun
moment en compte votre durée de
résidence en France est probablement un
facteur d'attractivité pour
l'immigration en France 5 ans SEM je
trouve je me prononce pas sur le quantum
mais l'idée
d'introduire une condition minimale de
séjours régulier en France avant de
pouvoir prétendre au bénéfice de
certaines prestations non contributive
ne me choque pas et et correspond
d'ailleurs à des propositions qui ont
été formulées par les républicains
depuis de nombreuses années absolument
vous restez avec moi Patrick stéphanini
je renvoie donc à votre rapport il est
en ligne et puis on va suivre évidemment
sur LCP ce débat parlementaire sur
l'immigration dès lundi matin dans
l'hémicycle vous savez que LCP vous
propose de le suivre en intégralité
peut-être qu'on y retrouvera quelques
amendements inspirés par par votre
rapport c'est l'heure des affranchis
allez vous allez pouvoir réagir à leur
partieprix on les accueille tout de
suite Fanny guinochet de franceino et
Yanis roder professeur d'histoire goéo
encienne Saint-Denis de la Fondation
Jean jores elles sont très
complémentaires ce soir vos vos deux
chroniques exactement qui a des effets
au plus haut de nos de nos cerveaux et
puis et puis les annonces de Gabriel
Atal mais on commence par Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
c'est vous qui nous la raconz elinava
bonsoir bonsoir et je vais vous parler
d'un sujet très sensible dans la
majorité demain c'est la niche des
républicains la journée d'initiative
parlementaire du groupe et la droite va
proposer de dénoncer l'accord
franco-algérien de 68 c'est un accord
conclu comme son nom l'indique entre la
France et l'Algérie et il crée un statut
particulier pour les ressortissants
algériens qui vient viennent en France
pour la droite c'est un traitement de
faveur qu'il faut dénoncer il y a
aujourd'hui un déséquilibre dans la
relation avec l'Algérie il y a aucune
raison désormais que l'Algérie et s
bénéficie de ces privilèges il faut que
nous rentrions pour l'Algérie dans le
droit commun donc c'est une mesure de de
justice de bon sens qui parlera tous les
Français ça c'est la position de la
droite et ça fait 3 semaines que la
majorité elle elle s'arrache les cheveux
je vous rappelle un peu les épisodes
acte 1 c'est la députée de Paris Astrid
panosian Bouvet qui est candidate pour
porter la voix du groupe sur ce texte
sauf que acte 2 bah on s'aperçoit que
elle elle est pour dénoncer cet accord
qu'elle veut voter le texte des
républicains acte 3 débat au sein du
groupe des voix s'élèves des cadres
notamment qui qui se qui se disent
inquiets attention à ne surtout pas
tendre les relations avec l'Algérie
elles sont suffisamment compliquées
comme cela et on a besoin de coopération
notamment avec la fameuse question des
laisser passer s consulaires
c'est-à-dire pour que l'Algérie accepte
de reprendre ses ressortissants quand la
France veut les expulser acte 4 le
gouvernement s'en mêle ça remonte à
l'Élysée et la pression fonctionne
puisqu'à la fin la position du groupe
Renaissance sera de voter contre et
l'oratrice du groupe et bien ce ne sert
plus à Street panousion Bouvet donc
c'est la fin de l'histoire la majorité
rentrer dans le rang alors il faudra
surveiller demain justement des les
votes renaissance pour savoir si la
consigne est suivie à 100 % mais dans la
majorité il y a d'autres composantes
horizon par exemple le parti d'eddouard
Philippe et bien groupe a annoncé qu'il
votera pour dénoncer cet accord vous
allez voter pour vous le groupe horizon
oui c'est une position de cohérence il y
a de cela plusieurs mois presque 6 mois
Édouard Philippe a fait cette
proposition je rappelle d'ailleurs que
cette résolution LR elle a été déposé
juste après un article où dor Philippe
faisait cette proposition peut-être les
a-t-il inspiré et dernier acte enfin
avant dernier acte on apprend le
président de la République en conseil
des ministres à ironiser c'est BF F qui
nous donne l'info je n'avais pas compris
que la politique étrangère de la France
était définie par le Parlement un petit
tacle à la droite et à son ancien
Premier ministre il y a quelques minutes
dans une interview dans le Figaro
ellisabeth borne rappelle qu'il pourrait
y avoir un nouvel avenant à cet accord
ça c'était un peu les coulisses la scène
elle se joue demain en séance à partir
de 9h ils ont raison les députés de
vouloir dénoncer cet accord où il faut
laisser tranquille le chef de l'État sur
le sujet il faut renégocier cet accord
c'est indispensable parce que c'est un
accord qui est aujourd'hui obsolète hein
pour l'essentiel il date de
1968 donc il est largement dépassé il ne
correspond plus à la situation des flux
migratoires entre les deux pays
euh si la dénonciation est votée demain
euh ce sera un instrument de pression
pour le gouvernement français qui
l'aidera à renégocier cet accord mais
l'objectif c'est de renégocier la
difficulté aussi c'est que la France
entretient avec l'Algérie des relations
complexes et que sur un sujet précis qui
est celui de la lutte contre le
terrorisme la coopération entre les
services de police français et les
services de police algériens
antiterroriste une coopération très
étroite il faut faire attention à ne pas
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain oui
c'est c'est tout le sujet on le rappelle
juste la résolution si elle est votée
elle est pas contraignante mais
effectivement de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée on surveille ce qui va se
passer une crise diplomatique mais on
sent que le politique voilà il est
toujours là chez vous Patrick stéphanini
Yanis roder quel est votre notre regard
de prof sur les annonces d'hier de
Gabriel Atal et ce choc des savoirs le
jour où notre classement au sein de de
PISA des gringoles notamment en ma alors
tout d'abord Myriam ce qui me semble
intéressant c'est que le ministre ne me
semble pas mu par une vision idéologique
mais plutôt être sur une ligne
pragmatique l'école reproduit
aujourd'hui les inégalités sociales
alors quand Gabriel attthal en prend
note et cherche à voir ce qui peut
fonctionner en se tournant notamment
vers les méthodes à l'étranger qui
marchent comme la méthode de
mathématique de Singapour voilà je me
dis pourquoi ne pas essayer dans mon
établissement si le brevet des collèges
portait uniquement sur le le contrôle
final nous aurions environ 10 % de reçus
notamment parce que le niveau
mathématique est catastrophique alors
oui il faut essayer des méthodes cell
qui March en tout cas celle qui marche
ailleurs tout en formant des profs à ses
pédagogies et notamment en commençant
par le premier degré et les groupes de
niveau on a entendu des syndicats
dénoncer le tri social si on faisait ces
groupes là en mathématique notamment ou
en français alors c'est une vraie
question et et nous avons déjà
expérimenté dans mon établissement il y
a 15 ans ce qu'on appelait des groupes
de besoins ce qui à peu près la même
chose que les groupes de de niveau et
les résultats ne furent pas en réalité
mirobolant depuis la suppression de ces
groupes dans mon établissement on peut
pas dire que les résultats ce soit non
plus amélioré alors peut-être qu'avec
des pédagogies adaptées peut-être en en
en transmettant des des connaissances
appuyées notamment dans le premier degré
çaela pourrait mieux fonctionner en tout
cas je pense que ça vaut le coup d'être
tenté j'entends certains effectivement
avoir peur de la stigmatisation la
stigmatisation des élèves élèves en
difficulté du genre tu es dans le groupe
des nuls mais je vois tous les ans des
élèves en souffrance dans les classes et
et nous manquons de temps et de moyens
pour remédier à leurs difficultés
parfois nous les abandonnons même malgré
nous alors essayons essayons les groupes
de niveau dont le ministre a précisé
qu'il nétait pas figé d'ailleurs prenons
en compte ses élèves prenons en compte
leurs difficultés en essayant de les
valoriser donner à chacun selon ses
besoins et non pas la même chose à tout
le monde me semble assez juste enfin le
redoublement la parole laissée au
professeur alors je crois y voir myiam
sans que cela soit explicitement dit la
volonté de rétablir une forme d'autorité
à l'école al oui je sa très bien et le
minist le sait aussi que les études ont
montré que le redoublement coûte cher et
n'est guerre profitable en terme de
niveau scolaire mais comme le dit
aujourd'hui le Figaro le ministre je
cite rend le pouvoir aux enseignants et
cela me semble important tous les élèves
ne sont pas conscients des enjeux et
j'en vois tous les ans se laisser bercer
ne pas investir leur scolarité le
résultat c'est qu'ils ne font rien voire
dérangent leurs camarades sans que cela
a de conséquence pour eux je crois que
nous avons besoin que le regard porté
par les élèves et leur famille sur les
enseignants et sur l'école change la
sanction a aussi des vertus et dans une
société où une partie de la jeunesse
dans la toutepuissance cherche des
limites qu'elle ne trouve pas ou qu'elle
ne trouve plus rappelez que rien n
acquis ni automatique qu'il faut
s'investir et mériter ce que l'on
obtient ne me semble pas une mauvaise
pédagogie comme le disait régist Debré
la vie n'est pas un grand pot de Nutella
très bien bon c'est un satisfait cite
d'un tout petit mot quelques secondes il
a du talent gabrielal dans ce post là
oui je pense que oui je pense aussi que
la le système éducatif français est
entré dans une crise profonde mais vous
la connaissez infiniment mieux que moi
et que ça facilite pas l'intégration des
enfants d'immigrés alors que
pendant des dizaines d'années le système
éducatif français a été un des facteurs
de l'intégration des immigrés en France
ça mériterait un nouveau débat qu'on
aura peut-être en coulisse à la fin de
cette émission Fanny vous nous dites que
ce classement PISA il révèle une baisse
de niveau mais à tous les étages pas
simplement de de nos élèves de de nos
collégiens de nos lycéens y compris de
nos cerveaux des médailles field on en a
plein en mathématiqu est-ce que on en
aurait moins et bien oui quand on
regarde effectivement ce ce classement
on se dit que à l'avenir on peut
s'inquiéter que peut-être ces
distinctions alors les médailles field
hein c'est les les prix Nobel en
mathématiques comme par exemple Cédric
Villani et bien peut-être demain il y a
peu moins de chance que l'on en est
parce que l'étude PISA montre que les
craques en math donc c'est-à-dire ces
tête c'est maateux pur jus ces très bons
élèves cette poignée très bons élèves et
bien ils se distinguaient dans les
classements et ils étaient largement
au-dessus des autres et que là en fait
dans ce nouveau classement cette
nouvelle édition ils ont rétrogradé donc
c'est Têt bien faite ça pose quand même
question et c'est vrai que c'était aussi
l'image de la France il y avait encore
quelques jours le président le patron de
HAWE
chinois grand géant technologique qui
fait des téléphones qui disait qu'il
allait installer une usine en France
parce que il y a des ingénieurs des
scientifiques qui sont bien formés et on
peut se dire que effectivement vu le
niveau aujourd'hui qui est révélé par
cette enquête PISA des enfants au
collège bien dans 10 ans ces
distinctions elles vont nous échapper et
nos ingénieurs ils vont pas être aussi
performants oui donc c'est grave et ça a
des conséquences économiques oui parce
que voilà c'est moins d'excellence ça
veut dire une économie moins performante
et alors il y a un économie justement
qui s'est penché sur le sujet c'est
Xavier jaravel qui est professeur
d'économie à la London School of
Economics qui est membre du C AE qui est
le Conseil d'analyse économique qui a
rattaché à Matignon et qui a qui s'est
penché sur ce sujet et qui montre
qu'effectivement ce manque d'innovation
risque de nous pénaliser et il estime
que ce retard éducatif français
notamment en math c'est 140 milliards
d'euros de PIB que l'on perd vous
imaginez ce que l'on pourrait faire avec
cette somme et il dit finalement que
c'est aussi important que d'autres
sujets comme ceux qui nous animent
actuellement sur notamment le nombre
d'heures que les Français travaille
alors la baisse du niveau en
mathématique elle affecte d'ailleurs
notre productivité notre efficacité
collective donc oui c'est important que
on s'en préoccupe alors comment réagir
alors bien déjà Yanis le disait il y a
une prise de conscience qui fait et
c'est vrai que les éléments qu'avancent
les pistes réforme qu'avance Gabriel
Atal même si c'est audacieux ça va
plutôt dans dans le bon sens tout comme
l'objectif affiché par Emmanuel Macron
de vouloir remettre un coup de de
projecteur et de booster sur la science
demain Emmanuel Macron va mettre en
place un Conseil présidentiel de la
science l'idée donc avec plusieurs
scientifiques de renom dont gen tiol
prix
Nobel d'économie pour rapprocher les
scientifiques et les politiques et c'est
vrai qu'il y a vraiment pas de temps à
perdre parce qu'on le voit le monde est
est dans de T bouleversement qu'on a
besoin des mateux on a besoin des
scientifiques même au plus haut niveau
que ce soit pour l'intelligence
artificielle ou encore la physique qu
bien sûr évidemment elle était elle
menacé notre excellence scientifique à
la française sans doute ceci dit restons
sur une note optimiste il y a des pays
comme la Finlande qui étaient tombé
assez bas dans le classement PISA et qui
en adoptant des mesures courageuse
énergique et innovante ont réussi à
remonter en tête de ce classement donc
la situation de la France c'est
difficile mais pas perdu mais pas perdu
merci allez on s'arrête là sur cette
note d'optimisme merci beaucoup les a
franchis Fanny guinochet France Info
Yanis roder fondation jeanas à très très
vite elsamondingava et puis Merci à VOUS
Patrick stéphanin d'être passé sur le
plateau d'lcp 1 heure en direct un grand
témoin chaque soir c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire
Jean-Pierre Gratien à
[Musique]
demain